[Music]
seven years ago one incredible story
blew up the internet when I was 22 I got
involved the Russian mafia I was a frat
boy on a class trip is this Igor here
for your protection he's very dangerous
and we're not to talk to or hang out
with him all I want to do is hang out
with him I did not speak Russian
all I knew how to say was
it was literally the best summer of my
life we robbing this guy
three years after those events
the story continues what is wrong with
this shirt
yo machine not today brother not today
my dad showed up you paid money to see
my son tell his made-up story about
robbing a train for the million times
it's a true story it took about two
seconds before he started making me
mental
he's a monster
are you the machine ma'am the party's
outside 23 years ago he was told the
only thing my father ever cared about
sorry this is some sort of tick tock
prank I'm about to lose my [__] it's
definitely a prank clearly that's a fake
gun
or not they're coming with me back to
Russia
[Music]
he's going down
why are you talking about fast like
you're on speed or something cause I'm
on speed oh more drugs
[Applause]
take off that shirt and show those sobs
who you really are now you gotta party
with me
he's the [__] machine
[Music]
time oh he's gonna shoot him in the leg
oh my God I'm going to [__] I killed
a man well technically you killed
several men
[Music]